the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today we have a new topic and
we're going to start to learn about
vector fields and line integrals so last
week we've been doing double integrals
for today we just forget all of that but
don't actually forget that you know put
it away in a corner of your mind it's
going to come back next week but what we
do today we're going to do line
integrals and these are completely
different things so it helps actually if
you don't think of double integrals at
all while doing line integrals so anyway
let's start with vector fields so what's
a vector field well a vector field is
something that's of a form well it's a
vector but where m and n the components
actually depend on x and y on the point
where you are so they are functions of x
and y so what that means concretely is
that at any point at every point in the
plane you have a vector okay so in a
cornfield at a way where you have corn
in a vector field everywhere you have a
vector that's how it works okay so a
good example of a vector field I don't
know if you've seen these maps that show
the wind but so here's some cool images
done by NASA so actually that's that's a
picture of the wind patterns of the
coast of California with Santa Ana winds
in case you're wondering what's been
going on recently so you have all of
these vectors that show you the velocity
of the air basically at every point I
mean of course you don't know that every
point because you know if you draw a
vector at absolutely all the points of a
plane then you just fill up everything
and you wouldn't see anything so you
just you know choose points and you draw
the vectors at those points so
here's another cool image of subject
down
that's a hurricane off the coast of
Mexico with the winds spiraling around
the hurricane so anyway it's kind of
hard to see you know you don't really
see all the vectors actually I guess the
autofocus is having trouble with it yeah
you can't really do it so I guess I'll
go back to the previous one but okay so
anyway a vector field is something where
at each point in the plane we have a
vector F that depends on x and y
so
this occurs in real life when you look
at velocity fields in a fluid for
example the wind that's what this
pictures show you know at every point
you have a velocity of a fluid that's
moving and the other example is force
field so now force fields are not
something out of Star Wars okay it's
just you know if you look at
gravitational attraction you know you
know that if you have a mass somewhere
well it will be attracted fall down
because of a gravity field of the earth
which means that at every point you have
a vector that's pointing down and same
thing in space you have the
gravitational field of planets stars and
so on so that's also an example of a
vector field because wherever you go you
would have that vector and what it is
depends on where you are so the examples
on the real world things like velocity
in a fluid force field where you have a
force that depends on the point where
you are so we're going to try to study
vector fields mathematically so we won't
really care what they are most of the
time but as we'll explore with them
define quantities and so on will very
often use these motivations to justify
why we would care about certain
quantities okay so the first thing we
have to figure out is how do we draw a
vector field you know how do you
generate a plot like that so let's
practice drawing a few vector fields
well let's start with let's say our very
first vector field will be just two I
plus J so it's kind of a silly vector
field because it doesn't actually depend
on x and y so that means it's the same
vector everywhere okay so I take which
of the plane and I take a vector 2 comma
1 I guess it points in that direction
it's 2 units to the right one up and I
just put that vector
everywhere okay so you know you just put
it at a few points all over the place
and when you think you have enough so
that you understand what's going on then
you stop
so here probably we don't need that many
I mean here I think we get the picture
okay so everywhere we have a vector two
comma one
now let's try to look at slightly more
interesting examples let's say I give
you a vector field x times I hat okay so
there's no J component so how would you
draw that maybe I don't need that much
well so first of all we know that this
guy is only in the I direction so it's
always horizontal like it doesn't have a
J component so everywhere it would be a
horizontal vector now the question is
how long is it well how long it is
depends on X so for example if X is zero
then this will be actually the zero
vector so X is zero that's here see on
the y axis maybe I should take a
different corner so if I'm on the y axis
I actually have the zero vector now if X
becomes positive small then I will have
actually a small positive multiple of I
so I will be going a little bit to the
right and then if I increase X then this
guy becomes larger so I get a longer
vector to the right if X is negative
when my vector field points to the left
instead so
it looks something like that any
questions about that picture okay so
usually we're not going to try to have
you know very accurate you know we won't
actually take time to plot the vector
field I carefully if we need to
computers can do it for us
but it's useful to have an idea of what
the vector field does roughly you know
whether it's getting larger and larger
in what direction it's pointing what are
the general features so just to you know
do a couple more I actually you see very
quickly that the examples I take in
lecture are pretty much always the same
ones so you know we'll be playing a lot
with these particular vector fields just
because they're good examples so let's
say I give you X I plus y J so that one
has an interesting geometric
signification significance if I take a
point X Y you know so there I want to
take the vector X Y how do I do that
well it's the same as a vector from the
origin to this point so I take this
vector and I copy it so that it starts
at my given point okay so it looks like
that and you know same thing at every
point
so it's a vector field that's pointing
radially away from the origin and its
magnitude increases with distance from
the origin okay so you don't have to do
whole you know as many as me but so the
idea is this vector field everywhere
points away from the origin and it's
magnitude is equal to the distance from
the origin so you know if this where for
example velocity fields
well that would tell you that you'd see
visually what's happening to your fluid
like here maybe you have a source at the
origin that's spewing fluid out and it's
flowing all the way away from that okay
let's do just a last one let's say I
give you minus y comma X what does that
look like that's an interesting one
actually it's
a nice one so let's see so let's say
that I have a point XY here okay so this
vector here is X comma Y but the vector
I want is negative Y comma X so what
does that look like
compared to yeah it's perpendicular to
the position to this vector okay if I
rotate this vector so let me maybe draw
a picture on the side if I take the
vector X Y then the vector with
components negative Y and X is going to
be like this it's the vector that I get
by rotating by 90 degrees
counterclockwise and of course I don't
want to put that vector at the origin I
want to put it at the point X Y so in
fact what I will do is something like
this okay and similarly here to be like
that like that and if I'm closer to the
origin then it looks a bit the same but
it's shorter okay and at the origin it's
zero and when I'm further away it
becomes even larger so see this vector
field if it was the motion of a fluid it
would correspond to a fluid that's just
going around the origin in circles
rotating at uniform speed okay so this
is actually the velocity field for
uniform rotation
and if you figure out you know how long
does it take for a piece a particle of
fluid to go all the way around well that
will be actually 2 pi because the length
of a circle is 2 pi times the radius so
that's actually at unit and get angular
velocity 1 Radian per second of our unit
plain ok so that's why this guy comes up
quite a lot in real life ok and you know
you can imagine lots of variations on
these of course you can also imagine
vector fields given by much more
complicated formulas and then you'll
have a hard time drawing them so maybe
you'll use a computer or maybe you'll
just give up and just do whatever
calculation you have to do without
trying to visualize the vector field but
if you have a nice simple one then it's
worth doing it because sometimes it will
give you insight about what we are going
to compute next ok any questions first
about these pictures No
okay oh yes sorry why and you're asking
if it should be why and so why can't a
negative X I think would be the other
way around see for example if I if I'm
at this point then Y is positive and X
is zero so if I take Y negative x I get
a positive first component and zero for
the second one so Y comma negative x
would be a rotation at unit speed in the
opposite direction okay so yeah and
there's a lot of tweaks you can do to it
but so if you flip the science you get
rotation in the other direction
yes how do I know how do I know it's at
unit angular velocity well that's
because if my angular velocity is one
then that means that the speed the
actual speed is equal to the distance
from the origin right because the length
I mean the arc length on a circle of a
certain radius is equal to the radius
times the angle so if the angle varies
at right one then I travel at speed
equal to the radius and that's what I do
here the length of this vector is equal
to the distance from the origin I mean
it's not obvious on the picture but
really the vector that I put here is the
same as this vector or dated so it has
the same length so that's why the
angular velocity is one it doesn't
really matter much anyway but
okay so now what are we going to do with
vector fields well we're going to do a
lot of things but let's you know let's
start somewhere so one thing you might
want to do with a vector field is so I'm
going to think from out of the situation
where we have a force okay so if you
have a force exerted on a particle and
the particle moves on some trajectory
then probably you've seen in physics
that the work done by the force
corresponds to the first dot product
with the displacement vector how much
you have moved your particle and of
course if you do just a you know
straight line trajectory or if the force
is constant that works well but if
you're moving on a complicated
trajectory and the force keeps changing
then actually you want to integrate that
over time so okay so we are going to the
first thing we'll do is learn how to
compute the work done by a vector field
and mathematically that's called the
line integral
okay so physically remember the work
done by a force is the force times the
distance and not precisely it's actually
the dot product between the force as a
vector and the displacement vector for a
small motion so say that you know your
point is moving from here to here you
have the displacement Delta R it's just
the change in the position vector if
it's a vector from the old position to
the new position and then you have your
force that's being exerted and you do
the dot product between them and that
will give you the work of the force
during this motion and the physical
significance of this well the work tells
you basically how much energy you have
to provide to actually perform this
motion just in case you haven't seen
this in 801 yet I'm hoping all of you
have heard about work somewhere but in
case it's completely mysterious that the
amount of energy you have to provide so
I actually know that the amount of
energy provided by the force sorry right
so if a force goes along the motion it
actually pushes the particle it provides
energy to it to do that motion and
conversely if you're trying to go
against the force then you have to
provide energy to the particle to be
able to do that so in particular the
work you know if this is the only force
that's taking place then the work will
be the variation in kinetic energy of
the particle along the motion so now
that's a good description for a small
motion but let's say that my particle is
not just doing that but you know it's
doing something complicated and my force
keeps changing so somehow maybe we have
a different force at every point so then
I want to find the total work done along
the motion well what I have to do is I
have to cut my trajectory into these
little pieces you know and for each of
them I have a vector along the
trajectory I have the force I do the dot
product and I sum them to
and of course the actual answer with the
actual answer I should actually cut into
smaller and smaller pieces and sum all
of the small contributions to work so in
fact it's going to be an integral okay
so along some trajectory
let's call see the trajectory for curve
you know some curve and here the work
adds up to an integral
which well we write this using the
notation integral along c of F dot DL
okay so we have to decode this notation
so one way to decode this is to say it's
a limit as we cut into smaller and
smaller pieces of the Sun over each
piece of the trajectory of the first at
the given point dot product with that
small vector along the trajectory and
well that's not how we're going to
compute it you know to compute it we do
things differently so how can we
actually compute it well what we can do
is say that actually we are cutting
things into no small time intervals so
the way that we split our ejector is we
just take you know a picture every say
millisecond so every millisecond we have
a new position and the motion you know
the amount by which you have moved
during each small time interval is
basically the velocity vector times the
amount of time so in fact let me just
rewrite this as when you do the dot
product between the force and how much
you have moved well if I just rewrite it
this way nothing's happened but what
this thing is actually is the velocity
vector
dr/dt so what I'm trying to say is that
I can actually compute my integral by
integrating F dot product with dr/dt
over time sometime you know whatever the
initial time to whatever the final time
is I integrate F dot product velocity DT
and of course I mean here when I say F I
mean F at the point on the trajectory at
time T right this guy depends on x and y
far so it depends on T ok I see a lot of
confused faces so let's do an example
and then I will ask you oh ok so now yes
that would be probably so here I need to
put a limit as delta T tends to 0 I get
my trajectory into smaller and smaller
time intervals for each time interval I
have a small motion which is essentially
the velocity times delta T and then I
dot that with a force and I sum them ok
so let's do an example let's say that we
do we want to find the work of this
force so I guess that's the last example
that we had ok so it's a force field
that tries to make everything in what it
somehow your first points along these
circles and let's say that our
trajectory our particle is moving along
the parametric curve x equals T y equals
T squared for T going from 0 to 1
ok so what that looks like what maybe I
should warn your picture
so our vector field oh whatever
and our trajectory if you try to plot
this when you see Y is actually x
squared so it's a piece of parabola that
goes from the origin to one one that's
what our curve looks like okay so we're
trying to find the work done by our
force along this trajectory I should
point out I mean you know if you're
asking me how did you get this that's
actually the wrong question
I didn't you know this is all part of
the data I have a force and I have a
trajectory and I want to find what's the
work done along that trajectory
these two guys I can choose completely
independently of each other so the
integral along c of F dot d R will be
well it's the integral from time 0 to
time one of f dot the velocity vector D
R DT DT so that will be the integral
from 0 to 1 of okay let's try to figure
it out so what is F
F at a point X Y is minus y comma X but
if I take the point where I am at time T
then X is T and Y is T squared okay so
here I plug x equals T y equals T
squared that will give me negative T
Square and T okay so now we'll put
negative T squared t dot product what is
the velocity vector well DX DT is just 1
dy DT is 2 T so the velocity vector is 1
+ 2 T DT ok so now we have to continue
calculation we get integral from 0 to 1
of what is this dot product well it's
negative T squared plus 2t squared I get
T squared
well maybe I'll write it negative T
squared plus 2t squared DT but ends up
being integral from 0 to 1 of T squared
DT which you all know how to integrate
and get 1/3 ok so that's the work done
by the force along this curve yes
well I got it by just taking the dot
product between the force and the
velocity
ok so let's in case you're wondering
things go like this
okay any questions on how we did this
calculation no yes
why can't you just do after the well
soon we'll be able to we don't know yet
what dia means or how to use it as a
symbol okay because you know we haven't
said yet I mean see this is a D vector R
that's kind of a strange thing to have
and certainly our is not a usual
variable when we have to be careful
about you know what are the rules what
does the symbol mean so I mean we're
going to see that right now and then we
can do it actually in a slightly more
efficient way but you can't just use I
mean R is not a scalar quantity R is a
position vector right so you can't
integrate F with respect to our we don't
know how to do that okay so oh yes sorry
I can see people up there because of the
spotlights but yes if I were to do so I
still can't hear you so
okay so question is if I took a
different trajectory from the origin to
that point 1 1 what will happen well the
answer is I would get something
different okay so for example let me try
to convince you of it for example say
that I chose say I chose to instead go
like face and then around like that then
you know first I wouldn't do any work
because here the force is perpendicular
to my motion and then I would be going
against the force all the way around so
if you get something that's negative
okay even if you don't see that just you
know except that face value what I'm
going to say now the value of a line
integral in general depends on how we
got from point A to point B and that's
why we have to compute it by using the
parametric equation for the curve it
really depends on what curve you choose
okay any other questions oh yes so yes
what happens when the force inflates the
trajectory well then actually you'd have
to solve a differential equation telling
you how the particle moves to find what
the trajectory is so that's something
that would you know be a very useful
topic and that's probably more like what
you will do in eighteen oh three or four
maybe you actually know how to do it in
this case so what we're trying to
develop here is a method to figure out
if we know what the trajectory is what
the work will be it doesn't tell us what
the trajectory will be but of course we
could also find that but here see I'm
not assuming for example that the
particle is moving just based on that
force maybe actually I'm here to you
know hold it in my hand and force it to
go where it's going or maybe there's
some avail that's taking it on that
trajectory or whatever so I can really
do it along any trajectory and if I
wanted to if I knew that its location we
could try to find the trajectory based
on what the force is but that's not what
we are doing here
okay so
next okay so let's try to make sense
when you asked if while ago in just a
few years ago what what can we do
directly with dr so dr c becomes somehow
a vector i mean when i replace it by dr
DT times DT it becomes something that's
a vector but with a DT next to it so in
fact well it's not really new but let's
see another another way to do it let's
say that our force has components m and
n I claim that we can write symbolically
vector D R stands for it's a vector with
components r DX and dy so now that's a
strange kind of vector I mean it's not a
real vector of course but as a notation
it's a pretty good notation because it
tells us that F dot d R is M DX plus n
dy and so in fact we'll very often right
instead of F the dr9 integral now see
we'll fight for line integral along c of
M DX plus n dy and so in this language
of course what we are integrating now
however when a vector field becomes a
differential but you should think of a2
as being pretty much the same thing
right it's like when you compare the
gradient of a function and it's
differential there are different
notations but they have the same content
ok so now the still remains the question
how do we compute this kind of integral
because it's more subtle than the
notation suggests it because m and n
both depend on x and y and if you just
integrate it with respect to X you'd be
left with Y is in there and you don't
want to be left with y's you want a
number at the end and see the catch is
along the curve
X
and why actually related to each other
so whenever we write this we have two
variables x and y but in fact along the
curve C we have only one parameter could
be X could be Y could be time whatever
you want but we have to actually express
everything in terms of that one
parameter and then we get a usual single
variable integral okay so how do we
evaluate things in this language well we
do it by substituting a parameter into
everything
okay so the method to evaluate is to
express X & Y in terms of a single
variable and then substitute that
variable
okay so let's for example we do for when
we hide up there just using these new
notations you'll see it's the same
calculation that with different
notations so in that example that we had
our vector field F was negative Y comma
X so what we are integrating is negative
Y DX plus X dy okay and see if we have
just this we don't know how to integrate
that I mean what you could try to come
up with like negative X Y or something
like that but that actually doesn't make
sense it doesn't work so what we'll do
is we'll actually have to express
everything in terms of the same variable
because it's a single integral we should
have only one variable and what that
variable will be well if we just do it
the same way that would just be T so how
do we express everything in terms of T
well we use the parametric equation we
know that X is T and Y is T squared okay
so we know what to do with these two
guys
what about DX and dy well it's easy we
just differentiate DX becomes DT dy
becomes 2t DT I'm just saying in a
different language what I say the other
with DX DT equals 1 dy DT equals 2t it's
the same thing but written slightly
differently so now so I'm going to do it
again I'm going to switch on one bot the
next one my integral becomes the
integral over C of negative Y is minus T
squared DT plus X is T times dy is 2t DT
and now that I have only T left it's
fine to say oh I have a usual single
variable integral of our variable T that
goes from 0 to 1 so now I can say yes
this is the integral from 0 to 1 of that
stuff well I can simplify a bit becomes
just T Square DT and I can compute it I
have negative T squared and then I have
plus 2t squared so I end up with
positive DT squared ok it's the same as
up there
okay any questions yes
one note when you do dy so what is dy dy
is the derivative of Y it's a
differential of Y Y is T squared so I
get 2t DT okay so I plug DT for DX I
plug 2t DT for dy and so on okay and
that's the general method so if you are
given a curve then you first have to
figure out how do you express x and y in
terms of the same thing and you get to
choose in general what parameter we use
you choose to paralyze your curve in
whatever way you want so the note that I
want to make is that this line integral
depends on the trajectory C but not on
the parameterization okay so you can
choose whichever variable you want so
for example what you could do is you
know when you know that you have a
trajectory you could also choose to
parameterize it as x equals say I don't
know x equals sine theta and y equals
sine square theta because Y is x squared
where theta goes from zero to PI over
two and then you could get DX and dy in
terms of D theta and you'd be able to do
it with a lot of trig and you would get
the same answer so this would be a
harder way to get the same thing okay so
what you should do in practice is use
you know the most reasonable way to
parameterize your your curve if you know
that here you have a piece of table y
equals x squared there's no way you will
put sine and sine squared you know you
could set I mean x equals T y equals T
square is very reasonable
you can even take a small shortcut and
say that your variable will be just X so
that means X you just keep it you know
as it is and then when you have why you
set y equals x squared dy equals 2x DX
and then you have an integral over X
that works okay so this one is not
practical but you know you get to choose
okay
so now let me tell you a bit more about
the geometry so we've said you know
here's how we compute it in general and
that's the general method for computing
a line integral for work you can always
do this try to find a diameter of the
simplest one express everything in terms
of that variable and then you have an
integral to compute but sometimes you
can actually save a lot of work by just
thinking geometrically about what this
all does okay so let me tell you about a
geometric approach so one thing I want
to remind you of first is what is this
vector dr well what is vector Delta R
you know if I take a very small piece of
a trajectory then my vector Delta R will
be tangent to the trajectory so it will
be going in the same direction as the
unit tangent vector T and what is its
length
well its length is the arc length along
the trajectory which is what we called
Delta s and where s was distance along
the trajectory so we can write vector dr
so we say that D X comma dy but that's
also T times DS it's a vector whose
Direction is tangent to the curve and
whose length element is actually the arc
length element I mean if you you know if
you don't like this notation think about
divide everything by DT then what we are
saying is DL DT that's a velocity vector
well in coordinates a velocity vector is
dx/dt dy/dt but more geometrically the
direction of the velocity vector is
tangent to the trajectory
it's magnitude is speed dsdt okay so
that's really the same thing
okay so if I say this that means that my
line integral of the dr well i say that
can write it as integral of M DX plus n
dy that's what I will do if I want to
actually compute it by computing the
integral but if instead I want to think
about it geometrically I could rewrite
it as f dot T DS okay so now you can
think of this you know F dot T is a
scalar quantity
it's the tangent component of my force
so I take my fault I project it to the
tangent direction to the trajectory and
then I integrate that along the curve
it's still the same thing and sometimes
it's easier to do it this way so here's
an example let's say so you know this is
bound to be easier
only when the field and the curve are
relatively simple and have a geometric
relation to each other you know they
give you an evil formula with you know x
cubed plus y to the fifth or whatever
there's very little chance that you will
be able to simplify it that way but
let's say that I'm doing say my
trajectory is just a circle of radius a
centered at the origin let's say I'm
doing that counterclockwise and let's
say that my vector field is X I plus YJ
okay so what does that look like well so
my trajectory is just this circle my
vector field remember X I plus y J
that's the one that's pointing radially
on the origin so hopefully if you have
good physics intuition here you already
know what the work is going to be right
it's going to be
zero because the force is perpendicular
to the motion well
now we can say it directly by saying
well if we take any point of the circle
sorry so if you have any point of a
circle then the tangent vector to the
circle will be tangent where it's
tangent to the circle so that means it's
perpendicular to the radial direction
while the force is pointing in the
radial direction so you have a right
angle between them
so f is perpendicular to T so f the T is
zero and the line integral of F dot T DS
is just zero see that's much easier than
writing well this is integral of X DX
plus y dy what do we do well we probably
we set x equals a cosine theta y equals
a sine theta we get a bunch of tract
things oh it cancels out to zero it's
not much harder but we save the time by
not even thinking about how to
parameterize things let's just do a last
one that was first one let's say now
that I take the same curve C but now my
vector field is the one that rotates
negative Y I plus X J okay so that means
and on my circle the tangent vector goes
like this and my vector field is also
going around so in fact at this point
the vector field will also be going in
the same direction okay so now F is
actually parallel to the tangent
direction so that means that the dot
product F dot T remember that's a
component of F in this direction that
will be the same as the length of F
right but what's the length of F on this
circle if this radius is a it's just
going to be a that's what we said
earlier about this vector field so at
every point this dot product is a now we
know how to integrate that quite quickly
because it becomes the integral of a DS
with a is a constant so we can take it
out and now what do we get when we
integrate ideas along C well we should
get the total length of the curve right
if we sum all the little pieces of out
length but we know that the length of
the circle of radius a is 2 pi a so we
get 2 PI a squared if we were to compute
that by hand well what would we do with
set so we would be computing integral of
minus y DX plus X dy we'd probably set
since 1 on the circle x equals a cos
theta y equals a sine theta for theta
between 0 & 2 pi so when we would get DX
and dy out of these so Y is a sine theta
DX is negative a sine theta D theta if
you differentiate a cosine plus a cos
theta a cos theta D theta well you'll
just end up with integral from 0 to 2 pi
of a squared times sine square theta
plus cosine square theta D theta that
becomes just 1 and you get the same
answer
it took about the same amount of time
because I did this coin tossing very
quickly okay but normally it takes about
you know at least twice the amount of
time to do it with the calculation so
that tells you sometimes it's worth
thinking geometrically